well i'm over here bawling my eyes out
because one of the best shows on
television has come to an end bones but
don't take it from me get ready for the
best tv show you have ever seen
bones that show was the perfect
combination of procedure and banter no i
mean these commercials ever run during
bones did you catch re-watch bones here
nice touch yes after six hell-raising
seasons lucifer has come to an end and i
kid you not it took me till the end of
the second to last episode to realize
lucifer's license plate isn't fellini
it's fallen one i'm not dumb i'm smart
now i don't want to waste any of your
time there is so much to unpack here so
let's get right into it oh and throw me
a like and subscribe i come out with new
devilish videos every week the series
finale begins with lucifer and chloe in
one hell of a predicament okay i'll stop
with the puns rory their daughter from
the future has been taken hostage by
vincent lamech who you may remember as
being the dude responsible for dan's
death in season 5. seriously the french
translation of his last name means the
dude unlike most seasons of lucifer
which sees articular character and team
take on a major antagonist last season
was lucifer's brother michael this
season focuses more on the emotional
journey of lucifer becoming god at the
end of season 5 he defeated michael yet
weeks after his victory has yet to
ascend to the throne something is
holding him back and matters are made
worse when a girl from the future
appears claiming to be lucifer's
daughter telling lucifer he'll disappear
on august 4th abandoning her and chloe
this is the main emotional driving force
of the season rory in the future angered
that her father didn't even show up to
chloe's deathbed to say goodbye
is so angered that it allows her to
teleport back in time days before
lucifer's supposed disappearance she
wants to make sure that the man who
abandoned her before she was even born
and wouldn't even show up to her
mother's deathbed pays so much of the
season is lucifer struggling with this
fact he hated his father god for
abandoning him as a child and can't
believe that he would do the same thing
to his own daughter rory tells him that
he was last seen on august 4th i'm
assuming 2021 at 10th and swanson in los
angeles so if he just steers clear of
that area on that day he hopes to change
fate but lumec has different plans in
the penultimate episode he escapes from
prison after one of the angels answered
a prayer which set a lion on the loose
and if that sounds crazy it totally is
you see with no god on the throne the
angels have been answering prayers
willy-nilly with some crazy unintended
consequences unintended consequences
that could actually lead to the end of
the world this puts lucifer in a tough
situation as deep down inside he doesn't
want to be god he hasn't found his true
calling
i've realised that being god is
it's just not my calling this is why for
much of the season lucifer puts off
becoming god and it's only when his
conscious and subconscious mind are
finally in sync something that doesn't
happen until episode 8 that he realizes
being god is just not for him there is
another purpose that has yet to be
revealed this leaves the job open for
amena deal who has always been the
angel's number one choice dan who is
sent to hell and brought back to earth
as a ghost finds out he's able to
inhabit bodies and does so with lamech
the man who killed him lucifer tells him
about when and where he'll die and his
biggest weakness his daughter but what
lucifer and dan don't know is that
lamech is listening in he'll use this
info to later kidnap rory and bring
lucifer to the exact spot he's supposed
to die but chloe and lucifer aren't
giving up without a fight they are
partners till the end which also happens
to be the title of the last episode rory
who came back in time fueled by the
anger she had for her father realizes
that ironically she was the one
responsible for her own abandonment the
reason i didn't have a father growing up
it was her kidnapping that eventually
gets lucifer killed for those of you who
may not have finished the season chloe
is currently pregnant with rory as
future rory is tied up lemeke and his
crew tear off rory's bladed feathers in
episode 3 we saw just how sharp these
are being able to cut through stone
these are the only things that can
physically hurt lucifer as we'll see
when he's cut by one of these thugs
brandishing a bladed feather lucifer is
supposed to be invulnerable at least
from non-supernatural weapons like guns
and bombs however these feathers are
different they come from rory who is
half angel half human so they can hurt
him not just the bait
you're also the weapon some may say it's
because he's vulnerable around chloe but
that went away in season five and if
that were the case he would have
succumbed to the gunshot wounds he'll
later sustain while fighting alongside
chloe in the shipping container room
lamech has a personal vendetta against
lucifer near the end of season 5 lucifer
whispered something in his ear that
caused him to experience endless
suffering and torture in his mind a fate
worse than death and part of the reason
lemek has captured rory is for lucifer
to reverse this if he doesn't he'll kill
rory there's a real kick-ass action
sequence entirely done in slow motion as
chloe and lucifer infiltrate lemek's
lair this is set to a song called my
body is a cage where the lyrics read my
body is a cage my mind holds the key
which is fitting since much of the
season deals with how our minds hold the
key to unlocking what's holding us back
there's no better example of this than
when lucifer loses his ability to fly
having to dig deep inside of himself to
find the key metaphorically so that he
can fly again chloe has a hand-hand
fight with one of the thugs and it's a
nice callback to when chloe trained with
mazzakin earlier in the season i want a
spar
[ __ ] this time however chloe doesn't
have azrael's necklace a trinket which
gave her super strength and
invulnerability which we saw at the
beginning of the season it also made her
lose control so it had to be taken away
from her making her vulnerable and
vulnerable she becomes getting stabbed
in the chest leaving only lucifer to
take on lamech lucifer leaves injured
chloe knowing that if the time loop is
correct she'll survive the injury and
then we get our final confrontation
lumec wants lucifer to get the torturous
voices out of his head or else he'll
kill rory but lucifer tells him the pain
he's feeling isn't really pain at all
it's guilt this gets at the core of what
the show believes hell to be an endless
torture where one faces their worst
guilt over and over again these are
referred to as hell loops and as we
found out at the end of season 5 with
lee garner one can overcome their loop
and make it to heaven to truly torture
someone you must know what they desire
this is why you'll often hear lucifer
ask suspects what they want more than
anything but we've never really heard
what lucifer desires he wants to see his
daughter grow up to be there for her to
be the father she deserves and the one
he never had lucifer's death would quash
those desires this is what would cause
him the most suffering and lucifer is
willing to take on this suffering
actually offering himself up to lumek
lamech was going to kill rory but
lucifer is the better prize and just as
lamech is about to kill him rory is
strengthened with rage and breaks free
of her confines lifting lamech into the
air now she could kill him here we even
see how her face turns similar to
lucifer's devil face but it's lucifer
who wants to show him mercy rory has to
be better than him you have to be better
than him you have to better than me and
rory relents putting him down they
embrace but lamech makes one last effort
to take them down before being shot by
chloe and impaled on a bunch of angel
feathers his last words are that he
wants to see what dan saw when he left
his body that bright heavenly light but
for lamech it'll only be darkness we'll
later see him in hell dan's story arc
this season dealt with him trying to
overcome his guilt so he could get out
of hell the only problem is is that he
doesn't know what that guilt is it's
only until he enters lamech's body and
says one last goodbye to his daughter
that he understands his guilt is rooted
in not believing he was the dad trixie
deserved what he doesn't realize is that
trixie thinks he was the best dad she
loves him unconditionally and there's
nothing to feel guilty about at all and
with this realization dan enters the
white light and ascends to heaven as
paramedics and police arrive on scene it
looks like lucifer and the gang have
saved the day but if he finally broke
this time loop how is rory still there
the only reason rory's here in the first
place is lucifer's abandonment but if
she's never abandoned then how is she
here so when the gang found out that
trixie was approached by dan and
lamech's body they realized it was
lucifer who helped dan realize his guilt
and break him out of the hell loop just
like he did with lee in season 5. then
it dawns on lucifer this was the reason
rory was sent back in time for him to
realize his proper calling in life is to
go back to hell not as its ruler but as
its healer in essence lucifer is
sacrificing being with his family to
save the millions of souls in hell this
realization prompts rory to be sucked
back to her time and it's ironically her
who makes chloe and lucifer promise not
to change anything in their timeline
because if they do lucifer may never
come to the realization that he must be
the healer of hell this is why chloe
never tells rory their real story about
what happened to her father and why
lucifer doesn't show up on chloe's
deathbed because if he did it would
throw the entire timeline off and rory
would never get angry go back in time
resulting in lucifer's revelation that
he must be the healer of lost souls i
hope everyone's following i actually
thought this was a brilliant way of
tying together this loop and explaining
a lot of the mysteries of the final
season at lux which lucifer gives half
of to amend a deal in episode 9 lucifer
says goodbye to chloe it's fitting that
the first and last time chloe and
lucifer meet takes place in the same
location with the same lime lucifer
morning star is that uh a stage name or
something
god-given i'm afraid lucifer morningstar
is that like a stage name or something
god-given i'm afraid it's also fitting
that lux literally means light as the
camera transitions us to the darkness of
hell where lucifer will begin his job of
healing they play the piano song heart
and soul together a fitting title
considering they have each other's heart
and soul and lucifer is off to mend the
souls of those below and then a deal
ends up on the throne in heaven with the
other angels basically showing him their
allegiance he'll also be able to freely
travel between heaven and earth to see
his half-angel half-human son charlie
who we even see sprouting some wings
whether or not charlie would have
celestial powers was a big concern for
amena deal in previous seasons it also
looks like ella and carol are together
ella had a huge reluctance to ever trust
a man again after it turned out her
ex-boyfriend was a serial killer but
she's overcome that and looks to be
running the foundation lucifer set up
for her to help young girls in stem
programs chloe has also returned to the
lapd we saw in episode nine and menadile
asked her if she'd be his personal
liaison between heaven and the lapd we
also see officer harris who looks to
have finally been promoted after years
being assigned to the beat as punishment
for pointing out the injustices going on
within the force we see dan in heaven
with his true love charlotte richards
now you may be asking yourself i thought
she left with god to a different
universe in season 5. that was actually
god s who had taken over charlotte's
body in previous seasons so charlotte's
actual soul would be in heaven even
though her job was an attorney here we
see the happily married couple mazzakin
and eve taking down a bad guy together
maz even gets a phone call which i
assume is the news chloe has given birth
to rory the whole crew celebrates as we
fast forward in time to where rory is
with her mother on her deathbed now with
the knowledge of everything chloe went
through to make sure the timeline
happened the way it was supposed to it
must have taken a tremendous amount of
strength to do what she did and as old
chloe passes away she is brought to
heaven where she sees amena deal who
says
are you ready to go home not gonna lie i
was like bawling my eyes out here but
not to worry rory will be able to visit
her mother in heaven she is half angel
after all in hell lucifer has begun the
process of helping lost souls overcome
their guilt and a room that's exactly
the same as his favorite therapist linda
it's pretty funny then that one of the
three people lucifer is helping is
linda's ex-husband rhys getty a man who
sought to prove that lucifer was the
devil he complains that he keeps making
the same mistakes in his hell loop but
lucifer says there's hope if the devil
can change for the better anyone can
while rhys wants to change the past
lucifer tells him that's the wrong
approach one needs to accept the past
because that's what makes them who they
are today and what better example than
lucifer a man who was caught in his own
loop of sex violence and debauchery who
escaped and became a better man for it
lemek even pops in offering that if
nothing works he can shoot rhys in the
face yeah he's to need a little bit more
time in therapy but this session is
paused when there's a knock on the door
it's chloe who has chosen to come down
from heaven to be lucifer's partner they
are partners till the end after all they
kiss as the door closes on them do not
disturb it's a heartwarming ending that
gives all our characters some closure
with an underlying message that no
matter what our past sins we can all
change and are worthy of forgiveness
with that being said it's time for me to
make like lucifer and re-watch all of
bones thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like and subscribe i'm always
coming out with new content for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much
you